what is it like you win a Grammy and
then next thing you know you're blinking
you're at the Super Bowl in a Super Bowl
commercial how crazy is that it's like
like the blessings just keep you know
just punching me in the face
oh the blessings are literally knocking
me out at this point where is your
Grammy where'd your words buddy you know
like the things I've found out about
awards so once you once you get the
awards you have to wait a few months you
get the actual award or all right but
when I get them I'm gonna put them like
like oh no on the coffee table or
something tell medo you want them out
and about I worry about I'll see if I
want everybody see it
okay tell me about what you tell me what
you can tell me about your Doritos
commercial my Doritos commercial was
just dropped you know we had so much fun
on set me Sam Elliot Billy Ray Cyrus it
was like going back to the old town road
video taking like a prequel really yeah
by the way you guys did a heck of a job
in a heck of a performance at the
Grammys what was it like putting that
together and adding BTS and all those
folks it was so fun like at first like I
was even like scared to even want to do
the Grammys but like you were scared to
do the Grammys I still get nervous
sometimes on stage but like specially in
front of all those people but like it
was fun to have BTS Naz Mason Ramsey the
spirit of young thug how did the nos
thing come about because the internet
went crazy with Nas and little nas acts
you know I just felt like that was the
thing that we had to eventually do yeah
and especially you know I'm thankful
that he even like considered doing it
because I know how that could like feel
like if somebody like but he took it as
respect and I have much respect for not
so you know I'm glad you know we have
this new song out videos what's come out
soon so
so Doritos has made some of the most
iconic commercials in Super Bowl history
including allowing users to make their
own right where does yours rank in that
Doritos history I think well I think the
number one spot num are you sure are you
sure you're gonna beat the baby flying
across the yard I'm beating the baby
flying across the yard
okay I'm saying there's some great ones
that's heavy
in your head I get I get it have you
digested how this year has been yet have
you taken like a moment to be able to
sit down and just relax and say this
ride has been so insane and crazy it's
like you know I I can't I guess cuz it's
just it just it's always current and
still happening it's like this 2020 just
doubted Grammy at the Super Bowl you
know I'm here with all these amazing
people me right you can say oh you can
say makes it would you one day want to
be on that stage and perform at the
halftime show I think that will be like
epic like incredible I hope so I will I
will maybe next year is that are you are
you gunning for that halftime show spot
maybe next year if I'm not doing
something else which is extremely
important
what could you be doing that's extremely
important no I don't know I do some
things sometimes I do some things
something more important than the Super
Bowl I could be you know like and
Beyonce's brunch or something
oh I mean but that's always before the
Super Bowl by the way how was that going
to the rock nation brunch and being
there with J and beyond time actually
didn't get to go through the rock
knowledge know what I did goes to the
Halloween party it was like a rooftop
event and like everybody was there like
everybody's just having fun and dancing
yeah yeah you had a good time had an
amazing time yeah Ujala you said hey be
say hey Beyonce I mean like we talked a
couple times she's the coolest J school
- yeah do you call Beyonce oh but you
almost always talk early I don't wanna
you don't wanna you don't wanna she
might be with the babies you know I've
been walking the kids all right who's
gonna win the losing win Super Bowl
Doritos but the Chiefs maybe two but
Doritos will win that was the best
answer you could've given
[Music]